la creciente preocupación por la subida
de los precios de los alimentos a nivel
mundial uno de los principales temas de
la cumbre de los ministros de exteriores
y de agricultura del g7 en stuttgart a
alemania con el ministro de agricultura
ucraniano como invitado especial of
trata por selene tenemos retos
las pérdidas de trigo pueden ser muy
importantes esperamos que las pérdidas
de la cosecha de maíz sean
proporcionalmente menores pero tenemos
que esperar y ver cómo se desarrollan
todos los factores en los próximos meses
y es que con la invasión rusa ucrania
las exportaciones mundiales de trigo y
aceite de girasol se han visto muy
afectadas ya que antes de la guerra el
90% de estas exportaciones salía desde
el mar negro ucraniano naciones unidas
ya ha advertido del alto riesgo para la
seguridad alimentaria mundial y varios
países del g7 sostienen que vladimir
putin tiene una responsabilidad directa
sobre el abastecimiento alimentario y
también sobre los daños materiales
causados por la guerra
entonces
andrés he pedido a los países del g7 que
adopten la legislación y pongan en
marcha todos los procedimientos
necesarios para confiscar los activos
soberanos rusos y dárselos a ucrania
para reconstruir nuestro país
to rebuild alcance mientras los países
vecinos de rusia han visto sus economías
fuertemente afectadas por el conflicto y
piden protección y sucre moldavia es el
vecino más frágil de ucrania tenemos una
serie de efectos negativos para nuestro
país a causa de esta guerra en la esfera
económica y humanitaria
hemos tenido una enorme ola de
refugiados y un miedo que van más allá
de lo económico ya que los últimos días
ha aumentado el temor a que la guerra
llegue a moldavia después de que los
separatistas pro rusos de la región
moldava de transnistria
culparán aquí de explosiones con drones
en la frontera